In late 1814, the great powers of Europe gathered
after the fall of Napoleon to discuss what
to do next.
At the time, the continent was in ruins.
The old order had been exploded as effectively
as if someone had detonated an atom bomb beneath
it.
Just as it would in 1945, Europe needed a
new roadmap, a blueprint for the future.
Designing that blueprint fell to one man:
Metternich.
The foreign minister of the Austrian Empire,
Metternich was a dandy, a womanizer, and a
comically pompous fop.
He was also one of the greatest diplomats
who ever lived.
Under his guidance, post-Napoleon Europe was
forged into a conservative system that would
last nearly 100 years.
His blueprint ensured the continent’s 19th
Century was far less bloody than either it’s
18th or 20th.
Yet Metternich also tried to strangle the
forces of nationalism at birth and, in doing
so, set the stage for his own destruction.
A master strategist to some, a vain buffoon
to others, this is the life of Europe’s
coachman.
Children of the Revolution
The world Metternich was born into would be
unrecognizable to us today.
The center of Europe was dominated not by
Germany, but by something known as the Holy
Roman Empire, a millennia-old collection of
tiny states all joined together.
It was in one of these tiny states on the
west bank of the Rhine that Metternich was
born, on May 15, 1773.
Or, to give him his full name: Klemens Wenzel
Nepomuk Lothar, Fürst von Metternich-Winneburg-Beilstein.
Although Metternich
was from the Germanic Holy Roman Empire, it
was France that had the biggest impact on
his early life.
Metternich’s home state was right on the
buffer zone with the France of Louis XVI,
so the boy grew up speaking better French
than he did German, despite his father being
an Austrian envoy.
This wasn’t all that unusual.
France exerted a powerful pull over continental
Europe in the 18th Century, and it seemed
totally natural that Metternich should be
sent off to the French city of Strasbourg
to complete his education in 1788.
Unfortunately for the teenage Metternich,
France at the end of the 1780s was a ticking
timebomb.
On July 14, 1789, years of political turmoil
in Paris exploded onto the streets.
A mob stormed the Bastille armory, lynching
the garrison commander.
It was the opening salvo of the French Revolution.
And it was about to consume the entire continent.
Despite being the sort of age when waving
the revolutionary flag might seem appealing,
Metternich was disgusted by the unfolding
drama.
For Metternich, any upending of the natural,
conservative order of Europe was anathema.
He decamped Strasbourg for Mainz post haste.
But Metternich was about to learn a very important
lesson: when the cannonball of revolution
gets rolling, there’s no escape.
In April, 1792, a French army whipped into
a revolutionary frenzy invaded the Holy Roman
Empire, burning, pillaging, destroying.
By now posted to a diplomatic position in
the Austrian Netherlands (AKA Belgium) alongside
his father, Metternich was forced to watch
in horror as the French annexed his family’s
home state in 1794, leaving them with nothing.
Barely had he got his head around this when
the French overran the Austrian Netherlands
and the boy and his father were forced to
flee to Vienna.
Although the Metternichs were now refugees,
they were still people of means, with good
connections to Austria’s elite.
So Metternich’s exile was less ‘Moses
in the desert’ and more ‘rich playboy
sleeping around Vienna’.
He even managed to marry Eleonore von Kaunitz,
the daughter of Austria’s former chancellor.
While Metternich was serially unfaithful to
her, the marriage still meant his family going
up in the world of Austrian politics.
But fate, and France, weren’t done with
Metternich.
On November 9, 1799, a French army officer
staged a coup in Paris, putting himself in
charge of the revolutionary war machine.
His name was Napoleon Bonaparte.
And he was about to plunge Europe into chaos.
The Napoleonic Era
From Metternich’s perspective, the 19th
Century must have felt like settling into
a comfy armchair that suddenly grows teeth
and devours you.
In 1801, Vienna’s newest man about town
was promoted to ambassador and sent first
to Dresden, and then to Berlin.
As Napoleon kept conquering, Metternich enjoyed
the Prussian capital’s nightlife, all while
gamely trying to persuade his hosts to join
Vienna in war against France.
For a guy known for his diplomatic acumen,
Metternich totally messed up this one.
After years of cajoling, the Prussians finally
put their foot down in 1805 and told the Austrian
fop “Nein!”
This was the moment the geopolitical armchair
swallowed the young ambassador whole.
On December 2, 1806, the Russian, Holy Roman,
and Austrian armies – minus Prussia – all
met to battle France at Austerlitz.
The Napoleonic army mopped the floor with
them.
The Third Coalition lost the battle so badly
the Holy Roman Empire was destroyed.
Austria was forced to become allies with France.
Would things have gone different if Prussia
had been there?
It’s hard to say, but they couldn’t exactly
have gone worse.
Still, Metternich’s catastrophic fail in
Berlin didn’t stop him from getting an ambassadorship
to Paris under Austria’s now pro-Napoleon
leadership.
Sadly, Metternich hadn’t learned from his
mistakes.
On May 2, 1808, an uprising in French-occupied
Spain triggered a crisis in Paris.
Egged on by Metternich’s breathless reports
that Napoleon was losing his grip on power,
Vienna took a risky gamble.
In 1809, Austria rolled everything on a surprise
attack.
Care to guess how this one went?
The War of the Fifth Coalition was a monumental
embarrassment for Austria.
Napoleon crushed them.
Not only that, he imposed one of the most
humiliating peace treaties in history.
Vienna lost a ton of territory, and was forced
to pay Paris a ton of money.
For Metternich personally, though, things
turned out surprisingly well.
In the aftermath of the new treaty, he escaped
blame.
Not only that, he got promoted.
On October 8, 1809 Emperor Francis I made
Metternich, then just 36 years old, foreign
minister.
He would hold the post for 40 years.
With Napoleon now basically in charge of Europe,
Austria’s new foreign minister was forced
to use all his legendary charm to try and
placate Paris.
This created some humiliating moments, such
as when Napoleon invaded Russia in 1812.
Austria was forced to send its own army along
in support of the French.
While Metternich managed to secure their nominal
independence under Austrian commanders, it
was crumbs from Napoleon’s table.
Or so it seemed.
When Napoleon’s latest adventure unexpectedly
blew up in his face, Austria was able to sign
a peace deal with the Russians.
Vienna could then sit out the catastrophic
French retreat across the continent.
For his part, Metternich didn’t believe
this was really the end of Napoleon.
In mid-1813, he tried to broker a peace between
France and Russia and Prussia that would allow
Napoleon to stay on the throne.
It was only when Napoleon said “non” that
Metternich signed Austria up to the Sixth
Coalition.
If you recognize the name “the Sixth Coalition”,
it’s because these are the guys that actually
did it, the ones that rid Europe of its tyrant.
On March 31, 1814, the armies of the Sixth
Coalition captured Paris.
With Cossacks marching down the banks of the
Seine, Napoleon finally threw in the towel.
The Petit Corporal abdicated and was exiled
to the island of Elba.
Across Europe, cries of victory went up.
There was just one teeny, tiny problem.
What the heck did everyone do now?
The Congress of Vienna #1: Creating the Congress
It’s time for us to take a quick step back
in time to something called the Treaty of
Utrecht.
Signed in 1713 at the end of the War of Spanish
Succession, the treaty was designed to keep
Europe’s superpowers from superkilling each
other by delicately balancing power between
them.
The French Revolution had exposed the limits
of this century old treaty.
Even before Napoleon’s defeat in 1814, everyone
knew a new treaty was needed, one that would
insure against another continent-wide war.
Unfortunately, all the great powers that had
just defeated France all wanted different
things.
We’ll get into the nitty gritty in a minute.
Just know for now that everyone in 1814 was
aware a mishandled post-Napoleon peace could
be catastrophic.
Before the Sixth Coalition had even won, they’d
agreed to a congress to hammer all their differences
out.
Somehow, Metternich convinced them to hold
it in Vienna.
The Congress of Vienna is one of the most
important diplomatic gatherings in history.
So, to make sure we can all get our heads
around this extremely important event, we’re
gonna take a quick detour now through the
main players.
Ready for some hardcore learning, guys?!
The four key powers at the congress were Austria
(obviously), Russia, Prussia, and Great Britain.
Since Austria was playing on their home turf,
that meant putting Metternich in charge of
everything.
His goals were to maintain the balance of
power, by ensuring post-war France didn’t
get too weak, and Russia and Prussia didn’t
get too strong.
Britain meanwhile sent over a guy called Viscount
Castlereagh, who broadly agreed with Metternich
about not destroying France, and not giving
Russia and Prussia everything.
Prussia sent a delegation who were led from
behind the scenes by the big boss, Frederick
Wilhelm III.
Ol’ Freddie’s grand plan was to hobble
France and gobble up Saxony for Berlin.
Finally, Russia sent the head honcho himself.
Tsar Alexander I was the Congress’s wild
card.
Not only was he negotiating for Russia personally,
he also wanted some odd things like giving
the Poles their own country; a big deal since
Prussia and Austria both owned Polish territory.
Although the table was designed for four people,
there was one last guy in the mix.
Charles-Maurice de Talleyrand-Périgord, better
known as just Talleyrand, was a French diplomat
and weasel extraordinaire.
He was so adaptable that he’d served under
Louis XVI, the French Revolutionary government,
and Napoleon.
And now he was in Vienna, claiming to represent
the recently-restored French monarch, Louis
XVIII.
Obviously, Prussia and Russia tried to laugh
Talleyrand out the room.
France had just been defeated!
There was no seat for him!
But Metternich thought differently.
Remember, he wanted to make France weaker
than under Napoleon, but not so weak that
it created a power vacuum Prussia might exploit.
So he teamed up with Castlereagh and got Talleyrand
into the table’s new fifth seat.
Those are our players: Metternich for Austria,
Castlereagh for Britain, Frederick Wilhelm
III for Prussia, Alexander I for Russia, and
Talleyrand for France.
All of them wanted different things, and all
of them held the fate of Europe in their hands.
As the entourages of these great men descended
on Vienna in the fall of 1814, the pendulum
of history could have swung any one of a trillion
ways.
Luckily for the conservative faction, Metternich
had a plan.
The Congress of Vienna #2: Parties and Politics
The words “Congress of Vienna” are probably
conjuring images of boring dudes in silly
clothes sitting around tables and talking
about impenetrable stuff.
Well, you couldn’t be more wrong.
The Congress of Vienna was designed by Metternich
to be the social event of the century.
There were parties almost every night.
Glittering balls held by the glow of candlelight.
Excursions to the greatest salons imperial
Vienna had to offer.
The wine flowed freely.
There was dancing.
Romantic liaisons.
Drunken affairs.
One source we’ve seen even claims two of
the top participants nearly got in a duel.
All of this debauchery wasn’t dereliction
of duty.
It was part of Metternich’s plan.
Remember, before he was Austrian foreign minister,
Metternich was a womanizing party animal in
Vienna.
This was his territory.
He was the master of the quiet conversation
over cigars in some smoky club.
Of a well placed word on the dancefloor.
Of buttering up someone over wine.
As the great men of history drank and danced
and seduced their way across the capital,
Metternich was working the crowd like a Silicon
Valley hotshot.
He had the perfect allies for his endeavor.
Talleyrand was even more of a social butterfly
than Metternich was.
While they had their differences, the two
were able to deploy a joint charm offensive
to make sure Russia and Prussia didn’t demand
France be carved up.
Castlereagh was even better.
While he wasn’t a total bro, he was representing
Britain, the country with the deepest pockets
in the world.
And Castlereagh, who saw eye to eye with Metternich
on many major issues, wasn’t afraid to splash
London’s cash to get what he wanted.
By February, 1815, the final shape of the
congress was clearly visible.
Alexander’s plan to liberate the Poles had
been bought off by offering him a chunk of
Poland, while Prussia had agreed to make do
with just three fifths of Saxony.
France, meanwhile, was to be pushed back into
its pre-revolutionary borders, smaller but
still powerful.
The Holy Roman Empire would be replaced with
39 states collectively known as the German
Confederation, with Austria as its head, naturally.
There were other outcomes, too, including
a guarantee of Swiss neutrality, and a commitment
to free trade along Europe’s rivers, a clause
cherished by Castlereagh.
But the big, headline news was the establishment
of the congress system.
Spearheaded by Metternich, the new system
would commit Europe’s great powers to meeting
every year or so to discuss events and (hopefully)
avoid war.
It also committed Europe’s powers to supporting
monarchs and empires over nationalist movements.
This was perhaps Metternich’s biggest contribution
to world history.
Metternich deeply believed that most Europeans
were natural conservatives who preferred order
and safety to the madness of revolution.
And now everyone was agreeing with him.
The Europe that emerged from the congress
wasn’t some shiny new thing, but a place
governed by king, family, and God.
It was everything Metternich had wanted, at
least in the broader sense.
But, before he got it, there was one last
nightmare to live through.
On March 7, 1814, Metternich was woken by
an aide with some terrible news, not just
for Metternich, but the entire congress.
Napoleon had escaped Elba.
Not only that, he was on his way back to France.
And the French people were rallying to his
cause.
Such news could only mean one thing.
It was time for war again.
The Age of Metternich
When the news of Napoleon’s escape reached
the congress, panic hit.
Within days, Metternich was making plans to
depart Vienna.
In France, the news caused the restored Louis
XVIII to flee the country.
It was like waking from a nightmare to find
you’re still dreaming.
Europe was almost paralyzed, by the fear that
Napoleon’s return would be even worse than
his first reign.
Luckily, things didn’t quite work out like
that.
The period of Napoleon’s return is known
as the Hundred Days, because that’s roughly
how long it lasted.
By June 18, 1815, the Seventh Coalition had
forced the Battle of Waterloo.
There, the British and the Prussians defeated
the Petit Corporal once and for all.
Back in Vienna, the Congress hadn’t actually
had time to disband by the time of Waterloo.
Metternich himself was still in the city.
Which turned out to be fortunate when Prussia
and Russia demanded France be made to pay
for this latest insult.
Metternich marshalled all his charm to make
sure the Congress’s outcome remained the
same as in February.
Remarkably, the Hundred Days changed almost
nothing.
In July, 1815, the Congress of Vienna finally
disbanded.
With it went the era of revolution, the era
of Napoleon.
In its place came the age of Metternich.
It was during this new age, as Europe was
cautiously settling into a life without war,
that Metternich became known as the Coachman
of Europe.
Certainly, he was in the driver’s seat on
many occasions.
In 1819, he headed the Carlsbad Conference
that committed the German Confederation to
cracking down hard on freedom of speech, repressing
liberal-national movements, and monitoring
universities for sedition.
He also headed a string of Great Power conferences.
So successful were these that Francis I made
Metternich Chancellor of Austria.
However, it wasn’t all roses for Europe’s
new driver.
Metternich wasn’t an idiot.
He knew history was turning in favor of national
movements, and he hoped to nip them in the
bud.
Back home, he actually drew up a plan for
Austria’s many ethnic groups to get their
own parliaments.
He hoped giving the Hungarians, Czechs, Italians,
and so-on a shred of autonomy would inoculate
Austria against further revolution.
But Francis shot him down.
The emperor was all like “dude, I loved
your secret police and crushing of free speech,
but your later stuff, with all that national
pride for Hungarians?
Not a fan.”
Still, Metternich remained a big figure on
the world stage.
Even when his Congress system broke down over
an argument with Britain about the Greek revolution,
people clung to the basic ideas he’d outlined
in Vienna.
In fact, by the 1830s, they were clinging
harder than ever.
On July 27, 1830, a three day rebellion broke
out in France that overthrew the restored
royals and replaced them with the July Monarchy.
Barely a month later, Belgium exploded in
a national uprising against the Netherlands.
Just three months after that, the Poles also
went into rebellion against their Russian
overlords.
And then 1831 rolled around and an Italian
uprising forced the Austrians into armed intervention.
For those who’d started to doubt Metternich’s
system, the multiple revolutions of 1830 – 1831
were a wakeup call.
The rulers of Europe clamped down hard on
nationalist feeling, which must have left
Metternich feeling pretty vindicated.
But the revolutions could be seen another
way, too.
A sign that Metternich’s new system was
built not atop firm ground, but a rumbling
volcano.
It would only be a matter of time before that
volcano erupted.
Decline and…
Even as Metternich’s stature grew on the
world stage, he was starting to slip into
the twilight of his career at home.
In the Viennese court, a dashing new liberal
Bohemian prince, Franz Anton, Graf von Kolowrat,
was suddenly the rising star, making Metternich
look clumsy and slow and reactionary.
Metternich’s vanity was so offended by this
that he started claiming every major policy
initiative in Austria as his own, even the
bad ones.
Not that Metternich made many good policies
himself.
Take the issue of succession.
Francis I’s eldest son Ferdinand was known
by everyone to be intellectually disabled
to the point of being unable to rule.
Francis had daughters and he had other sons,
all of whom could have succeeded him, but
Metternich was such a stickler for old fashioned,
eldest son only succession that he actually
talked Francis into not passing over Ferdinand.
And so it was that, on March 2, 1835, Ferdinand
I ascended to the Austrian throne.
Anyone hoping for a reformist ruler instead
got a guy who simply couldn’t rule.
As the years dragged by, Metternich’s choices
went from annoying to actively embarrassing.
In the late 1830s, he tried to revive his
congress system, but no other great powers
wanted to get involved.
Europe may have been shaped by Metternich’s
system, but it sure as heck didn’t want
to be ruled by him.
Not that all the things making Metternich
unpopular were his fault.
The famine that gripped Europe in the 1840s,
for example.
Or the financial panic that tipped parts of
the continent into recession.
What was Metternich’s fault, though, was
the secret police network watching everyone
at home.
Arresting people for dissent, giving them
nowhere to air their legitimate grievances.
Instead, people had to bottle everything up.
Every pang of hunger.
Every miserable indignity.
It was a recipe ripe for disaster.
All it needed was an outside shock to send
everything crashing down.
In 1848, that shock finally came.
No Country for One Old Man
If you study 19th Century European history
– or, better yet, just watch our videos
on the subject – 1848 is the year you’ll
keep coming back to, because that’s the
year that everything went bananas.
It started on February 23.
That day a French government ban on holding
banquets triggered a revolution that toppled
the July Monarchy.
The crash with which the king fell was enough
to bring Metternich tumbling down too.
By now, Metternich had been in power for nearly
forty years.
He was a symbol of everything that was old
and cautious and conservative in Europe.
So, when news of the latest French Revolution
reached Vienna, it made everyone hope Austria
could change too.
Within days of the July Monarchy’s collapse,
petitions were circulating through Vienna,
demanding liberalization.
These petitions weren’t calling for Metternich’s
head.
They just wanted an end to his system.
But since, under that system, the act of signing
a petition was illegal, Metternich demanded
all the tens of thousands of people who’d
put their names down be arrested.
You know that old phrase “to shoot yourself
through the foot?”
This was Metternich accidentally blowing his
own head off.
The short version of what happened next is
that Vienna’s poor, liberal students decided
to protest the government’s crackdown.
On March 13, 1848, a huge crowd gathered in
the city.
Metternich demanded the crowd be crushed.
The government’s anti-Metternich faction
counselled peace, with the result that it
was decided to maybe not crush the crowd,
but…
I dunno.
Squash them?
A little?
Whatever the correct metaphor, the cavalry
were sent in at exactly the wrong strength.
Wrong, because there weren’t enough of them
to disperse the crowd, or do anything but
spark a panic.
The panicked crowd attacked the cavalry, who
fought back, killing five students.
The firefight triggered a mass insurrection
and the civil guard were called in.
Unfortunately, the civil guard took one look
at the unfolding revolution and decided to
side with the revolutionaries.
With the entire city in revolt, Metternich
was given until 9pm to resign.
At first, Metternich refused.
But, as the clock ticked down and the situation
got uglier, reality finally dawned on the
aging Chancellor.
Just before the stroke of nine, Metternich
announced his resignation.
The very next day, March 14, 1848, he fled
into exile in London.
The age of Metternich was over.
The next two years were crazy.
As Metternich watched impotently from England,
Ferdinand I was overthrown and replaced with
Emperor Franz Joseph.
The Hungarians and Italians went into rebellion.
Prussia’s liberals revolted.
When the dust finally settled, though, one
thing was clear.
Somehow, against all the odds, Metternich’s
system was still standing.
Yep, the revolutions of 1848 basically failed.
The old order was restored across the continent.
Even France simply replaced the July Monarchy
with the dictatorship of Napoleon III.
In 1851, Metternich was even allowed to return
to Vienna.
It was a triumph, of sorts, and the old statesman
was soon back in the corridors of power.
But time was no longer on his side.
On June 11, 1859, Metternich’s health gave
out.
He passed away in Vienna, aged 86.
But while Metternich the man was gone, the
system he created would stay in place for
another 60 years.
In various guises, Metternich’s blueprint
for Europe remained until WWI.
It also succeeded in its mission to keep the
peace.
Between the Congress of Vienna and WWI, the
biggest war fought in mainland Europe was
the Franco-Prussian War.
Compared to the Napoleonic wars, or WWI and
WWII, it was peanuts.
For all his faults, Metternich was a man who
built something that lasted.
He may have been vain, repressive, and sometimes
actively stupid, but he was still the man
who sat in Europe’s driving seat for decades.
For better or for worse, our world would be
very different without him.